herzlich willkommen in meine trocken
wird heute möchte ich noch mal ein video
machen über meine kitchenaid viele haben
ja so nachgefragt nachdem ein kitchenaid
video gesehen haben
wieso ich nur eine gekauft habe ich habe
auch einen thermomix und was eben die
verteilung von so einer maschine sind
wie soll ich nicht meine alte
küchenmaschine behalten habe und das
möchte ich einfach in diesem video heute
klären
zuerst einmal möchte ich noch sagen dass
ich wirklich sei überraschend fand und
wirklich sehr toll dass die kitchen hält
und meinen videos so viel zuspruch
gefunden hat
es hat sich mittlerweile über 70 leute
gemeint ist die sich die kids schnell
kaufen wollten bzw diese schon gekauft
haben
einige haben wir schon fotos geschickt
von ihrer neuen maschine bei den anderen
läuft abgestellt grad noch und viele
andere sind jetzt gerade noch dabei ich
bekomme auch jeden tag immer mehr
anfragen und ich finde das wirklich toll
dass ihr bike so gut ankommt ich möchte
jetzt nur noch sagen dass dieses angebot
so wie es war also mit der kitchenaid
ich hätte vielleicht noch ganz kurz wie
viel zubehör dabei waren zwei kritischen
age die maschine mit schritten und mit
dem markt gewesen damals auch der flach
hörer in dieser flexiblen dabei und
kneten
dann bekommt ihr eine zweite
metallschüssel den fleischwolf vitro und
feinem aufsatz und die gemüse schneider
also dieser gemüse trommeln mit drei
verschiedenen trommeln das ganze eben
für 599 euro
und es ist es auch so dass man das nicht
auf einmal kaufen muss sondern
natürlich jetzt auch noch das angebot
das man sich die kids schon die
kitchenaid auf raten kaufen kann also
praktisch mit 0 und keine
bearbeitungsgebühren der preis bleibt
bei 590 euro auf zwölf monate das heißt
etwa 50 euro pro monat
so können wir das auch machen das klappt
auch alles per e mail
am anfang musste ich nämlich nicht genau
ob es geht oder nicht
aber es bestätigt das geht auf jeden
fall auch per e mail
das heißt auch wenn ihr weiter weg
wurden könnt ihr trotzdem die kind
schnell realisieren und das angebot das
gilt leider nur noch bis nächste woche
samstag also jetzt auch heute noch etwa
eine woche
und wie gesagt bekommt ihr auch ein
schütze mit dazu
zu den schützen muss ich sagen die uns
ich jetzt erstmal alle noch bedrucken
das muss ich ja alles mit hand machen
und wie gesagt es sind über 70 das heißt
ich jetzt arbeite dran weil man es mit
dabei helfen
dann bekommt ihr die schützen eben auch
also diejenigen die sich jetzt schon die
kitchenaid gekauft haben und schon die
ware erhalten haben dürfen wir gerne
meine e mails schreiben mit den
adressdaten und dann würde ich da die
spitze eben hinschicken
aber ich sage ich sage euch doch mal
bescheid bevor ich die losschicken
jetzt möchte ich in meinem video heute
noch wie gesagt den thermomix nehmen und
meine andere küchenmaschine
ich freue mich jetzt einfach mal was
ganz einfach ich zeige mich jetzt
einfach mal wie die ketscher aufschlägt
ist nämlich so dass woran ich es
eigentlich ganz gut zeigen kann
die hat nämlich den vorteil die habe ich
in meine tasche
system und mit dem und einfach bis auf
der schüssel boden und am kompletten
rand entlang des heißen das ist nicht
wie bei einer alten maschine so dass man
am rang stellt das ganze game hängen
bleibt und der teig nicht wirklich
verrührt wird sondern hier wird alles
verbirgt und ich muss nicht mehr teil
charme nachhelfen
ich wollte eine andere maschine und dann
zeige ich euch dass ich sage jetzt erst
mal den unterschied zwischen einer
gepflegt um einen thermomix den terminus
habe ich jetzt bereits seit über einem
jahr und die kind schnell gesagt seit 12
monaten und stellen unterschiedlich ein
nachfolgender mit meiner kindheit wach
ich also das heißt ich mache ihnen der
meinen rührteig mitgeteilt ich schlage
ihnen ihr die sahne
ich mach mein e type meine bregenz also
ich kann doch nicht alles schön luftig
aufschlagen und mit meinem thermomix
koch ich lieber also ich bin 25
verschiedene teile aber in dem mache ich
zum beispiel entweder nur ein hefeteig
wenn es schnell gehen muss oder man wird
tag am brandtag geht auch ganz komisch
dass man sich nicht auf dem herd führen
aber ansonsten benutze ich denen ganz
gerne oben meines ducken herzustellen
meine vorspeisen hauptspeisen ich bin
uns den um eine busse zu malen weil eine
zucker in zukunft also für so sachen und
ich muss halt sagen dass es viele gibt
die eben sagen braucht zum beispiel
keine kitchenaid wenn man einen
thermomix hat aber für mich wie gesagt
ich finde zum beispiel nennt biskuitteig
aus dem thermomix einfach nicht gut weil
da ein paar luft eingeschlagen wird
und ich finde gerade bis geteilt lebt ja
von
ruft also da muss eher luftig sein und
deswegen wer mein tipp 30 eine
küchenmaschine zulegen wlan gesagt ich
möchte die eine oder die andere würde
ich den rat geben wer erst ins backen
geht also ins kuchen backen sollte sich
eher mit schnee zu legen
aber wer vielleicht eher was wir sonst
machen möchte also mehr in richtung
kochen und dünsten und so weiter
das sollte sich den thermomix zu legen
also da macht man wirklich nichts falsch
damit ich mache damit meine sauce von
marmelade also dass ich eigentlich und
alles kann und dass ich so ein experte
fürs backen und ich habe es weiter
maschinen
ich bin nicht zufrieden und ich möchte
auch beide nicht mehr hergeben
wie gesagt es gibt leute die dann sagen
man braucht die 100er andere nicht ich
brauch beide natürlich habe ich auch
folgen gehen können holen die maschine
aber ich muss einfach sagen ich habe
eine zeit erspart uns dadurch ich kann
hier drin bei der gerichte ansetzen und
kochen lassen und dessen was anderes
machen und hier wie gesagt habe ich
einfach eine arbeitserleichterung weil
mit die maschine einfach die ganze
arbeit abnimmt
also wie gesagt die kitchenaid kosten
von räumen zeugung wenn ihr die haben
wollen wie gesagt eine e mail an nicht
schreiben an sale ist offen mit angie
mail.com ich leite dann eure daten
weiter es wäre ganz gut wenn ihr mir
gleich eure adresse mit dreien schreibt
in eure telefonnummer fand im rückfragen
entstehen und die der thermomix groß
sind wie gesagt im moment also ich habe
ihn für knapp 1000 euro gekauft und ich
glaube jetzt kostet über 1000 euro
vielleicht noch eine frage meine
kitchenaid hat die farbe himbeereis und
bei der firma weiter weg
die reben stellen können gibt es alle
fahrten ich habe mich beim anderen video
sondern link reingesetzt unter dem video
wir müssen aber schauen unter video da
steht die informationen zum müden video
und da steht
es müsste einfach mal anklicken und
dieses video verlinkt ich euch jetzt
hier in diesem video als video antwort
man könnte da mal reinschauen da habe
ich auch das zubehör vorgestellt
und ja alles erklärt das ist eigentlich
ziemlich selbsterklärend das video jetzt
zeige ich euch noch schnellem einem
vergleich zwischen meiner alten büchern
maschine und meiner kitchenaid die kennt
ihr aus meinen videos die hat mich jetzt
etwa vier wochen unterstützt und die
maschine habe ich von meiner schwester
geschenkt bekommt die hat die bei lidl
oder aldi gekauft ich weiß nicht mehr
wie viele die marke
und wie gesagt habe ich mir da alles
machen können
man merkt einfach den
qualitätsunterschied wäre mein buch lebt
vielleicht drei kilo die kitchenaid den
bau zwölf kilo
wie gesagt ich jeden tag opel ihrer
mitte und während an der schneebesen
rührt dann nimmt er nicht alles von hand
mit ein und kann den tag nicht richtig
wahr rühren und man muss halt dann
praktisch aber etwas nachhelfen
wie gesagt es ist nicht schlimm aber ich
will jetzt relativ nördlich wenn man das
jeden tag machen muss bei ihnen
kuchenteig machen will und ich zeige ich
jetzt einfach mal ich schlag ins überall
ein und zeigt euch einfach mal wie die
beiden rühren und dann könnt ihr auch
selbst schon den unterschied sehen
beide maschinen auf die höchste stufe
also bei
küchenmaschine auf stufe vier und bei
der kitchenaid auf stufe 10
also ich hatte die maschinen jetzt keine
minute an
und jetzt sehe ich jetzt hier den
unterschied hier habe ich eine ganz
locker aufgeschlagene ei masse also bei
der kitchenaid und wenig zeit noch
zucker mit rein geben wird für ein
biskuit teig weil es richtig schön steif
haben sich die eier kaum verwirrt was
ich sehe hier auch noch eisreste die
noch also diese eiweiß fäden die noch
nicht getrennt wurden und ist auch
ziemlich schwierig in dieser maschine
überhaupt so kleine mengen zu rühren
also da drin und eiweiß kann man
eigentlich gar nicht steif schlagen hier
in der maschine geht es wirklich gut es
eben nur als vorfeld als beispiel
ich möchte euch natürlich anderen
küchenmaschinen nicht madig sprechen
so aber hier seht ihr einfach den
unterschied der für mich eben
ausschlaggebend war mir eine kitchenaid
zuzulegen und der größte unterschied dem
update auf einen blick feststellen kann
ich natürlich die optik die kitchenaid
die habe ich auch mal als jugendliche in
großen einkaufscenter gesehen und hab
gesagt noch mal geben kann möchte ich so
eine küchenmaschine haben damals war für
mich die optik nur ausschlaggebend dass
ich einfach zwischen design was
eigentlich immer und die maschine ist
immer schön
man kann sich die farbe wählen die zu
einem passt oder die zur küche passt
oder zum lippenstift und
die maschine sieht nicht so toll aus
aber wie gesagt arbeitet auch und muss
man ihm selbst entscheiden was machst
dich so legen möchte was man sich gönnen
möchte ob man lieber etwas mehr geld
ausgibt und nach lebenszeit sport und
wie gesagt hat die kitchenaid fünf jahre
garantie unter anderem infos findet ihr
wie gesagt in meinem anderen video
alles andere würde auch den rahmen des
videos sprechen ich möchte es nicht viel
zum reden ich bin begeistert von der
maschine ich bin aber auch begeistert
von otto dix und von daher wünsche euch
ein paar schlägen euch die maschine zu
kaufen
die euch gefällt jetzt würde ich euch
viel spaß beim anrufen und wünsche euch
einen schönen tag und bis bald
was mir nur ein feld falls jemand
interesse an dieser küchenmaschine hat
wie gesagt die arbeitet noch und ich
will es eigentlich eher entsorgen also
von uns interesse hat und die gerne
möchte dann verschenke ich die weil sie
aus dem umkreis vielleicht kommt dann
meldet euch einfach per e mail bei mir
einfach an soll es trocken welt at
gmail.com und bevor alle fahren
diese kleinen sieg dieses kleinen süßen
schälchen hier kann man sich hier nicht
kaufen das habe ich von der türkheimer
mitgebracht aus dem urlaub und da gibt
es die eigentlich in jedem
touristenzentrum ich hatte die von
istanbul vom wasser darf sie in jeder
ecke fand ich sehr schön und wollte ich
einfach mal zeigen
aber jetzt schluss